est-ce qu'il est vrai que vous avez
l'intention de lâcher le Parti libéral
vous m'avez dit que vous aviez rajeuni
la formule mais si vous avez seulement
des vieilles questions comme ça
grandiose le côté poète
que je pourrais être aussi fier de
Québécois que ce soit
je pense qu'on est un héros personne
simple du peuple courageux que un code
d'éthique
il y avait toutes les qualités au monde
pour que un peuple complet a envie de le
suivre leur appartiendra la
détermination de René Lévêque a
fortement marqué les esprits au Québec
y compris ceux de nombreux jeunes qui
n'avaient pas encore l'âge de voter pour
lui j'avais 12 ans
je l'avais vu faire son on n'est pas un
petit peu pendant peut-être quelque
chose comme un
frissons j'avais le poil qui me dressait
je faisais mon Dieu je découvrais
c'était quoi et le Québec et la fierté
d'être Québécois
30 ans plus tard le comédien Emmanuel
Bilodeau réalise son plus grand rêve
celui d'incarner son héros d'enfance
dans une série télévisée moi j'ai
toujours aimé son sens aigu de la nuance
il y a jamais pris les Québécois pour
des imbéciles il parlait franc et par
les vrais mais parler aussi avec
intelligence j'ai jamais essayé de
réduire au plus simple dénominateur
commun parce que le public comprendra
pas non lui il faisait confiance
avant de devenir acteur le jeune
Bilodeau a d'abord été journaliste elle
était 1987 en tant que stagiaire au
journal La Presse il a eu l'occasion de
rencontrer René l'évêque pour une longue
interview quelques mois avant sa mort un
moment marquant
brillant comme c'était un entrevue avec
Bernard de Rome là qui était fin il
était là quand il était motivé il
répondait à toutes mes questions je suis
capables
j'ai l'enregistrement analogue que j'ai
mis sur le téléphone de cette fameuse
entrevue avec René Lévesque
dans un pays il faut tout de même que
c'est la Bible la population et que ce
soit clair mais vous savez beaucoup de
cet enregistrement là après coup pour le
jouer
et je ne vous suivent plus ça j'en suis
pas si sûr toute façon c'est pas une
raison pour me pointer en public me
souvenais de chaque mot de chaque
inflexion de voix de regard maintenant
chercher du Congrès en
le Gémeaux est remis à ce travail
d'acteur minutieux a d'ailleurs valu un
prix Gémeaux à Emmanuel Guillaudeau en
2007 l'indépendance du Québec c'était
comme un rêve René Lévesque un homme
politique de rêve le jouet c'est un rêve
ou c'est un rêve de gagner ça mais ça a
plus de but il était pas intéressé par
autre chose que par le bien commun puis
le
l'avancement de notre société garde ce
que c'est que je trouve j'ai gardé ça
moi
c'est comme si mon père était mort
[Musique]
à la prochaine fois
un collectif de billes se regroupés
autour de l'auteur Marc Tessier a aussi
fait revivre les moments forts de la vie
de René l'évêque certains épisodes
connus et d'autres qui sont moins que
quelqu'un de courage ça revenaient
souvent puis il dit que la deuxième
guerre mondiale pour lui c'était la
grande aventure de son siècle c'est pas
la grande tragédie c'était la grande
aventure
la première BD nous présente René
Lévêque à 22 ans agent de communication
pour l'armée américaine un jeune homme
téméraire confronté à la peur de mourir
c'est l'exemple du parfait québécois qui
s'en va à l'extérieur du pays qui
apprend tout ça qui nous représente
toute cette expérience là puis qui
travaille à ouvrir à défoncer les portes
il y avait quelque chose dans un évêque
je trouvais fantastique il y avait pas
un silice ou quelqu'un pour le prometer
toute l'expliquer les ok médiatiquement
tu vas dire ça ça va accrocher
raconte de petites histoires et
légalement insérés dans la grande
[Musique]
dans chapitre la nationalisation il y a
une page que j'en laisse ça je pris un
petit coup de trop qui est un petit peu
agressif vous avez un élevé puis un
éleva qui voit qui est sous on va
langage pas dans sa colère
toutes les cheminement de René-Lévesque
il y a eu des hauts puis des bas puis
personne savait qu'elle allait gagner
l'élection fait que je trouvais que
c'était une célébration une explosion
c'est comme des feux d'artifices qu'on
met de la couleur c'est une bonne idée
du dessinateur c'était un appât
dramatique
[Musique]
il y avait une certaine dignité Renée
l'évêque quelque chose qui m'aimait dans
son approche quand il gagne puis qui se
rend compte que il y a la responsabilité
maintenant il y a réussi ben moi ça ça
vient me chercher
dans l'histoire d'un
point qui est élu la pression lui tombe
dessus puis son premier réflexe c'est
pas d'aller fêter c'est de faire oh mon
dieu
qu'est-ce que je veux faire maintenant
avec toutes ces responsabilités
35 ans après sa rencontre avec lui 14
ans après avoir joué sa vie à la
télévision Emmanuel Bilodeau est encore
imprégné de la forte personnalité de
René l'évêque au point où il a choisi
d'emprunter sa voix et ses limites pour
conclure son plus récent spectacle sur
scène
une culture qui se remplit jamais
inquiet de leur survivance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
tellement de d'humidité puis de
conviction c'est un genre d'anti-héros
est-ce que pour beaucoup de monde parce
que c'est le modèle à suivre pour faire
de la politique
on lui doit beaucoup à ce petit bonhomme
là plein de courage qui s'est battu pour
nous autres et après pour tout le monde
son dos puis il s'en va avec ça puis pas
il va se battre avec ça puis il y a
réussi pour moi c'est ça un héros si je
vous ai bien compris vous êtes en train
de dire à la prochaine fois